let's end with some financial advice
from the from the great warren buffett
oh
so warren buffett apparently has four
money rules that says if you want to be
a millionaire follow these four rules i
feel like we're constantly bringing up
warren buffett's rules on money yeah
here for them four of many um but
basically here they are number one
pay yourself first
pay yourself first right save
then spend not spend
then save love it save that money save
10 of your paycheck invest 10 of your
paycheck whatever it is then you spend
and then there's levels to that cover
your needs then your wants and then last
you indulge in any sort of luxuries that
you got going on right cars clothes
jewelry we talk about this all the time
what are the luxuries that cost you
money that always depreciate cars
clothes jewelry cars clothes jewelry
save that money then you can spend on
your needs then on your wants and then
on sort of what they call
indulgent luxuries that's number one
from warren buffett number two
this kind of goes with the luxuries be
careful splurging on brands aka brand
names we've talked about this before we
give a belt analogy right yeah like
you've seen the picture with um
uh warren buffett and bill gates and
it's like
you know
300 billion dollars in one picture not
one gucci belt in sight you've seen this
yeah yeah yeah okay so basically saying
there is a big dif you have three belts
one's five bucks one's 50 bucks one's
500 bucks which belt would you get david
a five a 50 and a 500 belt me i just
need my pants to be up give me the five
one okay so here's the deal so basically
they're saying that there is a huge
difference between the 5 and the 50. the
5 is actually probably a piece of
the 50 stable reliable gets the job done
keep your pants up the 500 is just a
name brand there's not that much of a
difference between the 50 the 500 let me
say that again there's a huge difference
between the five
and the 50. this is gonna fall apart in
a few weeks it's crap it's bs you bought
it at the dollar store the 50 is going
to be decent it's going to keep your
pants up it's going to be a
value play a value investment the 500
bucks is just a name brand yeah you're
just buying the brand so basically what
i'm saying is if those are three options
get the 50 belt
50 not the 500
and not necessarily the cheap
ghetto ass brand hmm and you think this
applies to everything
i think in general
oh
yes i do think that i'm thinking of it
from
i do a lot of the production here yes
with a lot of help and um
when we're buying systems
of course you're not gonna buy the
hundred dollar system
and then the ten thousand dollar system
is like uh but then it's like the ten
thousand dollar system will be
working and able for the next fifty
years for you the thousand dollar system
will work but might be outdated in the
next five
so is it the same all across the board i
think this is specifically name brands
luxuries luxury clothing things that's
what it is that kind of stuff yes buying
name brand
buying name brands yeah then i yeah i
totally agree then the five buck one
will definitely break down on you i
think this is really applicable when it
comes to clothes
yeah 100 and yeah yeah
um
number three
and this is what we just touched about
with dave ramsey susie orman and the
rest of the folks he says be careful
about taking out loans aka debt what i
call the worst four-letter word in the
world it's not it's worse than
bleep bleep bleep leap leap is dead okay
he says if you buy things you don't need
you will soon sell things that you do
need that's what warren buffett has said
on many occasions so understand the
credit card games all right so listen i
i have a credit card i paid off on full
every single month i understand that if
i don't pay it off in full every single
month i'm going to have 19 interest to
pay so i don't want to have that in my
life i pay it off in full if you pay it
late you're gonna have to pay a penalty
or a late fee understand that so thank
you warren we've kind of spent some time
on debt but understand be careful taking
out loans we get that
um
and then he talks about number four be
careful about investing with borrowed
money that's happening a lot these days
where people are basically buying on
margin to buy crypto or basically
spending money taking out loans to
invest in other properties yeah it's
tough to win that game okay he says for
the record buffer has cautioned against
borrowing money to invest in securities
aka buying on margin
that's basically what happened with
a lot of the um
gamestop people they were buying on
margin
and next thing you know
the rug got pulled out of them yeah now
they owe a lot more money than they
actually expected so that's warren
buffett
what do you think
yeah i mean hard to argue with the
the legend goat himself warren buffett
on his four rules to become a
millionaire but i guess and something
that just kind of came up uh
what it
where do we hold warren buffett account
i'm thinking back to kiyosaki and his
wrong prediction
warren buffett
has been wrong
like who's who's arguing warren buffett
who's saying hey this guy
warren buffett yeah i don't know about
him i'm wrong he's been wrong before
has that been a thing he has been he
hasn't he doesn't come out and make
these ridiculous salacious he's very
conservative he's very conservative he's
a value investor because a lot of these
things basically says the best he could
do is an s p 500 fund yeah index fund he
talks about kind of like what you said
earlier it's like yeah okay i know
anyway
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken